hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on lead chess
gonna hop into hourly super Blitz Arena
joining just about five minutes late
still 52 minutes to go 3-0
let's get some reps in
that guy feels a little bit misplaced
um you know what
I'm just going to allow this capture
I like this grip over E4 now
Preserve my Bishop
and I have the better Bishop
and the E4 Square
maybe maybe Knight here instead of
castles was a little bit better
but uh right about now I think I could
go hunting for this E4 Square
get rid of this Knight hop in here
basically I want to play this position
where I don't allow this bishop to
exchange itself off for any of my miners
let's give this a guy a kick right now
hmm all right
so this is the big difference in the
position
it's poison Knight because I get the
fork
E4 as a whole
E5 is not
so this doubled Pawn is
especially useful
all right I guess that's all that's
going to happen on the queen side
missing some trick
let's centralize
so one of these has to well I don't know
how to get rid of this name
that's so easy
uh maybe I can move forward with this
drive this night
back
or maybe hold off let me not go anywhere
just yet
so I have a decision I'll take with the
queen
maybe I could think about maneuvering my
knight to this Square
seems like it takes forever
is there even a path
it's tough to even see a path
uh I don't know let me back off for a
moment
um how do I get my knight here
let's start with this
I'll go maybe for the B5 break
yeah let's get this in right now
if there's some serious pressure against
this a pawn my Bishop could always fall
back
all right so this is looking kind of
serious now
I could have maybe flicked in
Queenie for
feel like I should be tracking a pawn
down soon
or not
let's start with this maybe Rook here or
even Queen here
Queen D3 and then Circle a knight into
this Square
and go with this one
this Pond feels way too far away to pose
any serious threat
so for example if I start with this one
this guy's out of the both of these are
out of play
yeah I'm on the Rook there
I think they're in a tough spot no
matter what
I guess I'll Exchange
get this Pawn
all right Knight on C6
it's a bit maybe
a little bit of a lazy move
and I just played there
I am up The Rook though
here we could take this
just promote
that was probably better kill the Knight
all right either way
the win is a win
how many games have been played I am
only back one game
47 in change
see if we get next 206 are in there
the top guys
Eagle the emperor Brian
all right
berserk game here Brian
somebody anybody all right the almighty
Blues
they'd have six
oh once more
feels like a
theme
so
it's like a familiar structure okay I
may have to watch out for a little bit
I'm gonna go here because there's a sort
of
this uh double attack idea
so we're following now into a similar
structure
let's get out of here
and the other game I allowed the Knight
to Pivot on this Square i castled
instead of fighting for E5
so now no 95 here
and now these these sort of moves
there's no guarantee E4 is going to
be a useful move and so
this may very well turn out to be a
just kind of a wasteful move it's tough
to really suggest a clear plan forward
for black after White
yeah let's hop in now see if they
straighten things out and it's tough
with H3 in there
I just I was able to straighten up my
pawns with H3 in there if ever F3 I have
that jump
and now I could look to create a Duo
all right so to take or not is the
question
maybe I could continue to try and grab
more space
um I think I should capture though
yeah let's capture and now hop to this
Square
so in the other game E5 wasn't a hole
both of these are holes but the the big
difference here is that I am able to
conveniently watch over the E5 square
with my Bishop
and I don't know if I want to even Jump
Right In just yet
let's start with this one
and then maybe hop in next
it feels super cluttered
for white
there I guess we start with this one
this Rook is stuck
so now Bishop there it's mate
I'm even threatening Queen here and just
tripled up and oh you know what I missed
Bishop here
I could fall back
all right they didn't see that move
um I don't know how this is prevented
oh am I even threatening that
what am I talking about
miscalculating
all right
that was a bit silly
okay let's go with this I went to this
square instead of F7 by the way so that
I could step up and still have the trio
Bishop there not entirely sure
what the story is
trying to do something active with the
bishop but
no no if the H file opens up I could get
into H2 so yeah this is going to be
lights out shortly
no fancy Rook moves
to set up a check it should be mate next
move okay there's a rook F2 move
and just capture though all right
theories end
43 and change
maybe get a white game now
and a different structure hopefully
okay let's go with D4
okay
Knight F3
Queen's Indian defense
okay watch over C4
and recapture the Knight
develop a new piece they can allow me to
play E4
no
but now that there's this tension my
queen
[Music]
um
some battery soon on this
C files
looking
pretty appealing
okay
let's unmask my light Square Bishop for
starters
and also vacate F3 for my other Knight
so we're probably going to have many
pieces exchanged although when that
night goes there I'm thinking about this
because they're kind of cluttered
third ranked ninth second ranked night
not to me not a not a healthy mix of
options for this guy now
well one one legal move
okay
and let's get this guy here so I'm
keying in on this one break
this this bishop move there's nothing
fancy happening on this diagonal so
they're setting this one up I suppose
it feels
kind of weakening though maybe now's the
time to capture
let me let's make this capture
so now that with this Pawn on F6 this
Knight can't get to its favorite Square
anymore
I'm guessing
a reinforcement of my Center is called
for
seems healthy
I have the better Bishop once again
I'm gonna cut out the night jump
I want to keep another night on board
and also look forward to an expansion
although
we want to be a little bit careful about
that let's start with this move
if I play B4 I think A5 is
appealing
Queen F5 might be a move
or even Bishop H3
now that I actually now that the Rook
isn't on the a file this seems less
effective
so I'm fighting fighting this uh C5
break right now
um let's go with this one
may end up with a similar structure
again
I'm planning on taking with my e-pawn
Knight takes Knight
and then going here
and trying to do something in the E6
Square so
there might be an accident happening
very soon
this skewer the queen is on F6
okay
hmm
see if I could provoke a weakness
I think my Bishop will stand well on D3
and I don't see a fantastic way for
black to try and take advantage of these
light squares now that I've abandoned
the the fiend keto post
could go here I guess we'll probably
probably be uh
trading a whole lot
uh let's go with this one this was one
of my ideas
I feel like if I go here we'll just
trade trade trade away
let's try and get some
some break on the clean side Rook on A7
be nice I have the healthier King
the Cozier structure for my king
if ever this
I'm ready to jump in here that's not a
fun move to make
all right so now I'm threatening this
and then Queen takes C6
this I'd rather only play that okay so I
should probably take right now
let's jump in here
go for this
um my initial thought was to take with
the B Pawn
but I'm going to take with this guy
because I like this D4 Square for my
knight
threading a fork now
and scoot over
get one Rook off I want to keep my Rook
trained on the a file
and from here
expand a little bit cut out this Square
once more this similar structure
and how to make forward progress
I think my king on D4 could be pretty
good
so Knight on A5
might be winning
some material now
crashing through
and let's do like this
Target the palm
I'll take right now
all right they're down on time
three games
and three similar structures
on the
King side in all games for me
see if we could get a fourth
okay slav land
let's just watch over that pun
okay that's a little
odd
I don't know that I could take advantage
of it though
so there are some quick holes
uh uh I guess we'll go here right now
D6
let's go for this
all right I'm denied
not really sure how to improve here
I'm sort of passing with that move
Bishop D3 okay this Knight is pinned
and one of my ideas here was to trade
light script Bishops
so what's black considering
now maybe maybe this is a move okay
uh let's go with this one
even though this is their bad Bishop I
think my queen
could be no not so much my queen
um you know active but my knight I like
that I can jump on this Square
um
yeah I'm not sure how this one's gonna
play out I am threatening at the moment
Knight takes D5 oh they walked into that
Knight is still pinned
so I just want a pawn
probably be exchanging a minor piece
or two
do I have something fancy
uh I don't think so let's take care
and how many times do I want to take
get taken then push
let's let's go with this first
hmm maybe this Pawn Falls though let's
go with this one
still keeping pressure on a
all the queen side puns
um I'm also watching over my bee Pawn
and yeah this right here I wanna
not end up with an isolated Pawn so it's
a four versus three in the king side my
opponent has the flight Square
I still need the flight Square so
hmm
and I guess we exchange
not thrilled about this
and let's get the flight Square in here
get to the file
all right
hmm
really down on the clock
see these Queen c6c4 moves are met with
some Rook check
sort of irritating I I want to basically
get on this diagonal
it's a roundabout way but my eye is on
C3
get the Queens off and hopefully obtain
an active Rook position
is all I'm really looking for
I should mention when my queen is on B5
if I played B4 Rooks Rook D5 was kind of
bothering me I think
down on the clock maybe I could key in
on the the B Pawn now
these guys are likely to be traded and
I'm gonna have to try and convert
a
four versus three
and here we are
not sure what the best approach is to
try and win here I know that my opponent
can't exchange Rooks
all right
I want to be able to move my F Pawn
eventually
let me give some checks
might be repetition
yeah it's a draw
time loss but objective draw position
um I think if I could make a quick
adjustment
with that game it would be
my decision with the a pawn
eight I think when I played A4 and it
was met with A5
uh yeah I think A5 was a good reply so
let's not go for that again
only taking on C4 after the bishop has
moved
May soon have a imbalanced or uh excuse
me a
an isolated Pawn position
uh let's try this structure
well they're not taking on B4 okay
let's back off
D5 is available
D5 is still there
trying for a quick B5 okay we're gonna
get a bunch of Trades
Bishop takes interesting
reasoning that the the Knight is going
to be
a real tough guy
I'm guessing
opposite color Bishops Maybe
hmm
didn't expect that one
that feels a little too greedy right now
hmm yeah that was a blunder they missed
that I'm on that one twice
whoops
just have a piece
keep on developing
I feel like I could
trade Queens soon let's go with this one
now we're offering a queen Exchange
and if it's declined I get a piece
another piece
I feel like I kind of lucked out there
I was in a worse position
let's get the flight Square all my
pieces are stable coordinated
not looking to win any material
I'm just looking to trade
this is a step towards trading Knight C4
probably try and duck it Knight D4
there's no follow-up pin like this this
I can take the bishop and I'm defending
got the H7 Square I also have this
covered I was thinking a check might be
there
yeah
resigned okay while this is going really
fast
only 26 minutes remaining 27
got 16 378 in there
never could forget me as in first
Dallas is right on my heels
a lot of sixteens
what a fire
all but one has fire okay
let's try an E4 game
before E5
okay babysit the E4 Pawn
uh let's go for this
and then this I don't want to Castle
just yet
because I have a plan
going here I don't want this to hit my
Bishop
this was my plan
Knight G4 I have Knight E3
so I'm not castling so I can make this
pivot
typically the bishop will want to stay
on its home Square because this knight
jump to F5 is
kind of serious I could have also
considered
this capture I am threatening it now I'm
expecting Knight G6
and okay I missed that I'm
I'm on that one
so I'm up a pawn
and now my knight is threatened
Bishop F4
um developing but it's also on an
unprotected square and I feel like I'm
vulnerable
so let's not do that
Queen is unprotected this splendor's a
piece
it's the lone Defender
uh okay let's develop like this
I'm gonna think of it I don't know if
I'm if I would really want to take the
Knight even though it crushes the king
side structure
Knight F4 I have to watch over
so with that in mind maybe
maybe let's first flick this move in
Bishop takes tonight I could take here
okay
so now even if the Knight lands here
maybe I could work around it so I'm I am
threatening that
okay let's improve this Knight
back off or something better
think forward first
Queen here
yeah that might be something
the more I look at it
I am threatening this move
yeah I'm threatening some fancy stuff
now Bishop F6 captures Queen H6 into G7
is mate
I think that's a good defense
now there's lateral defensive G7
so
at the same time I have a check on B
tree
um I don't know if I want to even go
there though
let's keep that in reserve
keep in mind as soon as this Knight
moves my queen is threatened
I am on this
the forward Knight moves are under
control
can be pinned if he goes to C4
oh
really asking for trouble there
really asking for trouble
all right let's start with this one
the Knight has to block and then this is
setting up some tricks
Knight is pinned
okay
we could just get the Queens off by at
this point
the Queen's off
oh it's the Knight isn't pinned anymore
anymore but
it sort of is
they're being sneaky there
gotta watch out for these nights
just want to trade them all
small lead in development
watching out for a break keeping this
guy here
recapture in any way but
still wanna
play with the
some precision
improve the king
yeah so this this guy interferes
really well with the all the different
Pawn breaks
that must have been a slip I probably
wanted to stack the Rooks
okay
never forget me
they berserked and then resigned not
sure what the story is with that
have they done that with other games
no I just didn't want to play
all right
24 of fire 20 minutes to go 4 22 in
there now
Minco
okay Carol Khan you know what let's
shift gears and not go with D5
Maybe
I'll take we go into an ending
nope
all right
foreign
Knight F6 just yet because I may want to
play Bishop here although that's going
to be tough to manage
all right I need more development
this in the map
is my plan
I takes I'm removing it right away okay
I have to be really careful now about my
C6 Square
okay
I'm focusing a lot on the queen side
this is where I have some
some possible play
and they are they are cutting out the
night move
um
let's get this one in
prepare to go Rook C8
may want to play Knight C5 enough to
play this move soon
or maybe I could play Knight C5 now
um I don't think I'm ready for it
pretty sure I have to keep the Knight
out of F5
I'm not a fan of my position
I don't think my Bishop is doing a whole
lot okay now that there's not as much
pressure
on this point I think I could dive in
here
entirely sure
what exactly I'm gaining by doing this
and let's back off
Knight H6
thinking Knight H6 Knight H6 might be
there still
okay
really do feel like I'm super vulnerable
to tactics where are they
are they disconnected
uh yeah I think I'm just okay they're
back even on the clock
there's a play Rook f8 soon I think
I'd really like to have this bishop here
to drive the Knight away
okay
that could happen anytime
I also think about recapturing
on CA with my Bishop
yeah white will want to be really weigh
the B4 move carefully you kick one night
away but also give me the C4 Square
okay
let's get the file
Bishop C8
Queen there
okay maybe this right now
I'm blundering something
I don't think I am now Knight here I
have this in the night's dead
okay
I'd like to get the Queens off or maybe
maybe I wanna
stabilize my knight for a second
maybe we repeat
okay I thought Queen H6 might be played
watch out for this
these guys could end up being targets
let's start with this
maybe both of my Knights belong in these
dark squares
might have been a bad decision here
ooh
these guys are running really fast now
just gonna drive me back
hmm I'm on this
this is a really strong night
careful
hmm losing in this final position
it's putting a premium on just moving
fast with seconds remaining
okay
all right let's go Bishop G5
that's the that's my variety
Bishop F4 or G5
and I don't want to see E5 hit so easily
they may be getting that in no matter
what I do
hmm
clean there no
yeah let's run it like this
and keep pushing me around yep
all right I should look to strike at the
light squares as soon as possible
they will be strengthening my Center
it feels like
black can easily end up getting overrun
the
with the Pawns
I'm treating my dark Square Bishop as
the Expendable one it's the bad Bishop
um so
I really don't mind too much if it's
hunted one way or the other
uh let's start with this
tightening
this capture and then starting to push
okay
King is on a light so both my queen and
Bishop
I should be watching out for
some tricks
Knight right here might be a move
all right let's get out of this pin now
maybe this is on in the night
can't go to E5 now
so
and it really doesn't have a wonderful
Square do I want to do that though
maybe Rook B5
or G6
maybe G6 let's watch over this break
there may be some undermining idea of
the D4 Pawn
this is crossing my mind
all right
what about let's go with this now
actually
I'm threatening this Pawn
now I guess I'm also cutting out Knight
A5
might be a pit stop on C5 I could even
consider this move
okay
um get my Apon contributing
let's go with this Knight here is a move
but I could play here
let's do this
okay
and now
if I play here isn't this kind of tricky
to defend
might be some Rook G6 my queen is there
to reinforce some sacrificial attack
I think I need to break this open
giving a square to the Knight but I have
a counter attack watching this
in the process feels a little loose for
me
I am I think I may be over committed on
the queen side
there may be some Perpetual idea I'm
thinking Rook G6 give up the night and
then take here now my Bishop should
provide enough cover
okay
very tempted right now to just take
I could take with the pawn
or maybe insist that the Knight goes
somewhere else yeah let's do it like
this put more pressure on the night
it's
a best piece
some move like this probably isn't
working this is hitting hard now
the loss of the night with an attack
against the queen
time Edge the Knight moves this
collapses
his back rank mates if I if I get here I
think
it's going to be a big problem I'll be
able to even if they try to stir up some
trouble
coordinate on the king side
and you're gonna have to tend to the
back rank threats
and so here we are
get some trades in
maybe everything gets traded Queen's
coming off soon
yeah I'm just up
a big pawn two connected passers
end up winning the night soon
right there he just runs
okay back to tournament land see how
many more we get in one more for sure
Dallas is in first and also in a game
how many games
nine
okay
some space
H6 G5 Knight H5 I think is
necessary now there's no Knight H5
all right
well let's Castle
and now that that Knight has moved let's
play here
I want this trade in
and once once more focusing on
good and bad Bishops
let's continue to focus on this F5
Square connector Rooks
and I'm playing here not only to
reinforce this Pawn but pivot with this
Knight
my second rank Knight needs some work
I think this guy wants to stick around
right here
I am giving the Knight a square
all right
new square for my Bishop
this is turning out to be quite the
maneuvering game
I believe I am
the better side
night there
prepared to work around the night
watch out for the one intersection
Square
right here
and reinforce this
in time I could look to drive this night
away but I want to cover the key squares
first so
this night
is my favorite is currently my favorite
piece
um
I think
well now that this Pawn is here I could
think a bit more about the capture
let me let me get this one in first
maybe plant this Pawn this Knight here
right away I think I like this idea
and let's let's kill
this uh this break I have a fork but I'm
valuing this Knight as if it's a
I don't know it's worth at least a rook
I feel
now that the Rook is not on the a file I
could look to push this guy around
yeah so now he's
he's to find a new home
it's a phoenix
um
let me just go here for a second there
might be a sacrifice on H3 and then a
capture on F3 I just want to kill that
idea
not sure what the queen move is doing
okay I see a plan
C5 break
so they're going for it
let's just take this straight away
and rule out any pawn breaks
there's no Rook G6
I may be setting up this
although I'm thinking more about just
simply trading Queens
being up the piece
tracking down upon
this Knight is under control by a pawn
this Bishop's under control by the black
pawns it's just these two have to worry
about
and there's only one point to
Converge on G2 it's covered
tough to suggest a move this Knight
isn't doing anything on B5
could bring him over to D3 excuse me uh
E6
let's do that
it's Forks
I guess I could take him on the night
Queen takes Knight I have mate
that's me
yeah they're in a tough spot I think it
uh is all kind of coming back to that
well
I think Knight C5 I think when that
Bishop G5 move is there H6 Bishop H4 G5
Bishop G3 and then Knight H5 have to be
played otherwise I get Knight D2 in and
the Knight H5 move is cut out all
together
okay we're back to uh similar structures
we had in
games one two and three maybe I'm gonna
take here
yep here we are again
and this will be the final game
I don't want them to have any space
okay interesting
there's a square given up
B4 is now a whole
um
let's go here
maybe my queen belongs on this square
that might have been better
and we'll see
might be prepping this
I'm prepared to take okay now that this
is
available I'm going to hop right to it
now this is a move
the more I look at it I don't like my
Bishop on B4 I think I want to bring it
back
I think maybe I want to kick the Knight
first though
no let's bring it back straight away
don't watch for variations where this
diagonal opens up but I'm not quite
seeing how that happens
maybe some fancy stuff like Rook here
okay definitely not taking that night
I guess we'll take
F6 is the threat
supporting this and also I think put my
Bishop right here is nice
that's the plan
have this defended twice
if G4 I take once
I think this guy needs to be captured
yeah so now
start with this stop any
idea with the G Pawn post this guy here
um
let's get my king off this diagonal
watch out for the clock
maybe should have prepared this a little
bit more
Yeah the more I look at it the more I
don't like that I played that move so
fast
wouldn't mind having the Queens off
and get my king
on this Square
watch over these two
if this I could exchange and take here
no I don't think there are any great
Pawn breaks for white
oh let's let's go somewhere else with
this
just shuffling now
oh it ends up repetition I was going to
do something different there
whoops I didn't realize it was
repetition in the end
I wanted to end up playing Bishop B6 and
I don't know if I could really make
progress prefer my position but I think
I was a little bit too quick with B6 in
the end
okay
uh in the end that one wasn't going to
count either way but I wanted to play on
got how many games in 10.
ended up in first 36 34 32 top three
all right
that one went by really fast
video games all
right anyhow that's all for this video
uh feel free to leave any feedback in
the comments section below hope you
enjoyed it and maybe
took a thing or two away from it that's
all for now take care bye